[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview sur
rtl france place aujourd'hui au thème de
la militarisation de l'espace une
conquête sociale qui a commencé lors de
la guerre froide mais qui aujourd'hui se
mondialise de plus en plus la france
peut-elle rivaliser avec les états unis
la chine ou la russie à l'heure où
washington ambitionne par exemple de
retourner sur la lune très prochainement
alors également par exemple pékin et
moscou annoncent la construction
prochaine d'une base lunaire
on en parle avec philippe gauthier
président de la société et mejia qui
collaborent avec l'état dans cette
mission de la militarisation de l'espace
à bonjour philippe gautier merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
bonjour avant de s'intéresser un peu
plus à vous et à votre société
on se souvient que emmanuel macron avait
pris la parole le président français à
l'été 2010 9
il avait annoncé vouloir créer un
commandement militaire de l'espace c'est
quoi et comment avez vous accueilli
cette déclaration pas écouté on leur a
bien accueilli on pourra reparler parce
qu'effectivement il ya des enjeux qui
sont considérables sur ce domaine
on l'a bien accueilli parce que parce
qu'il fallait effectivement avoir à la
fois des compétences est une
organisation militaire qu'ils soient qui
soient dédiés à ce sujet c'était des
compétences qui est qui était qui
étaient déjà présentes mais qui était un
petit peu éparpillé localisé dans un
certain nombre d'organisations donc le
fait effectivement d'avoir un
commandement de l'espace qui est inclus
dans une une armée qui s'appelle
maintenant l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace
avec à la fois une stratégie une
organisation des moyens des ressources
est un fait un point qui est extrêmement
important pour à la fois définir une
stratégie de surveillance de l'espace
des menaces d'identification des menaces
et puis aussi piloté une une stratégie
de réponse à ces menaces donc c'est
plutôt une une très bonne nouvelle et un
interlocuteur pour les industriels que
nous sommes qui est précieux vous êtes
donc le président de la société et mejia
vous travaillez en étroite collaboration
avec l'état français avec l'armée quel
est votre rôle dans cette mission voulue
par le gouvernement de la militarisation
de l'espace
oui alors pour situer les choses et
mejia est une société qui travaille
depuis depuis de longues des années dans
le dans le domaine de l'espace et qui a
accéléré son développement de façon
relativement récente il ya trois quatre
dernières années
en concevant et en fabricant de petits
satellites
quand des petits satellites sont
typiquement des satellites qui font
moins de moins de 5 50 kg pour donner un
ordre d'idée les gros satellites de
télécommunication ça fait à peu près six
tonnes voilà donc c'est vraiment petit
ça bénéficie de tous les progrès de la
miniaturisation ont fait en matière
électronique en particulier en fait on
fait beaucoup plus petit avec des
fonctions qui sont qui sont souvent bien
plus performante que des systèmes
beaucoup plus gros enfin disons qu'on
assiste à la même dynamique de
miniaturisation que dans les domaines
grand public aussi satellite les petits
satellites les petits satellites ils
servent à quoi ils servent
ils servent à observer c'est à dire une
façon très concrète ils peuvent emporter
des caméras qui vont
qui vont produire des images de la terre
d'une précision d'ailleurs qui est assez
forte
ils servent aussi à communiquer ils
servent à réceptionner à transmettre de
petits messages typiquement par exemple
ça ce forcément les usages militaires
mais lorsqu'on appelle y'at-il un outil
internet of things donc réceptionner des
balises c'est par exemple là pour vous
donner un exemple ont produit les des
satellites d'une constellation qui
s'appelle kinesis et dont dans le sujet
c'est ça c'est effectivement de suivre
des millions de points des balises
voilà donc ils servent à ça
principalement je dirais
observation et puis et puis connectivité
on parle de la militarisation de
l'espace et un terme assez compliqué on
sait qu'il ya aussi la rationalisation
de l'espace et puis évidemment au départ
la conquête de l'espace quelles sont les
différences entre ces trois termes oui
et alors
bon déjà l'espace
l'espace il faut un petit peu définir
parce que finalement dans votre
introduction vous évoquez la lune mars
l'exploration c'est un espace un petit
peu lointain mais mais mais qui
effectivement très actif et très
emblématique de ce qui se passe
actuellement l'espace un petit peu plus
proche c'est la zone qui se situe on va
dire entre quelques quelques quelques
centaines et et 40000 km de la terre
donc c'est vraiment enfin l'espace dans
lequel on voit ce sujet alors cette
personnalisation militarisation c'est
l'espace qui est assez proche qui est
qui est autour de la terre donc cet
espace là il est il est peuplé de
satellites et il devient même encombré
de satellites
alors pour pour situer un petit peu le
sujet de la miniaturisation
militarisation il faut comprendre
quelques éléments le premier élément
c'est que l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques alors
militaires pourquoi parce que les
militaires ont besoin de l'espace pour
recueillir du renseignement pour
communiquer sur ce qu'on appelle les
théâtres d'opération donc pour établir
des liaisons de communication pour
naviguer aussi c'est à dire pour piloter
un ensemble de choses dont je fais
allusion faite aux systèmes de
navigation type gps ou galileo qui est
le système européen
voilà donc les militaires ont un besoin
essentiel est de plus en plus essentiel
pour effectivement pouvoir mener leurs
opérations de façon autonome et
souveraine
voilà donc c'est l'autre élément de
contexte de l'espace et que l'espace est
devenu aussi un sujet économique qui est
tout à fait essentiel l'industrie
l'économie ne peut plus fonctionner
effectivement sans avoir les moyens de
positionnement de navigation et ses 700
millions d'euros supplémentaires d'ici
2025 une somme qui s'ajoute aux 3
milliards d'euros prévus dans pour le
spatial des défenses dans la loi de
programmation militaire française 2019
de 2022 oui voilà donc exactement ce cas
ce qu'a mentionné la ministre et
président également c'est le fait que
finalement il s'agit de il faut il faut
maintenant protéger les actifs
militaires c'est à dire les les les
satellites qui sont qui sont
essentielles ou au fonctionnement des
opérations des armées françaises alors
les protégés pourquoi parce que
effectivement by un centre de menaces
qui sont apparus dès des manifestations
plus ou moins plus ou moins hostiles ou
plus ou moins louches
si vous voulez de de tel ou tel pays
bon il ya des choses qui commencent à
être connus pardon lesquels bon je vais
pas me substituer
si vous voulez aux propos des des
militaires au mini mini cement fin à un
certain nombre de pays qui effectivement
on peut avoir des agissements qui sont
qui sont qui sont un peu un peu suspect
voilà et donc donc il s'agit en fait il
s'agit dans un premier temps de
finalement de surveiller tout ça alors
deux
et ça a été une partie une partie
effectivement des de la direction qui a
été qui a été prise dans lequel
effectivement c'était mejia gaubert
alors surveiller ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire effectivement observé à partir
du sol avec des moyens optiques radars
etc
qu'est ce qui ce qui se passait dans les
nazis lui passé à lhassa l'espionnage ou
non si vous laissez passer pas vraiment
de l'espionnage c'est la surveillance au
même titre que s'ils voulaient sur la
mer il ya rien de très nouveau c'est à
dire que l'espace proche espace de la
terre devient devient devient très
important devient devient
devient stratégique devient aussi
encombré parce que l'autre élément c'est
qu'il ya un nombre considérable de
satellites qui sont qui sont lancés qui
sont pour la plupart d'ailleurs des
satellites commerciaux un usage
télécommunications enfin on a entendu
évidemment tous les initiatives
américaines avec des sociétés comme ce p
6 sardines que kiki qui lancent eux des
milliers de satellites dont il ya aussi
des sujets par ailleurs de débris enfin
il ya il ya plein de raisons si vous
voulez de mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe en orbite au niveau de l'espace
mais s'ils voulaient bon voilà on l'a
toujours fait on observe par exemple en
un système de surveillance maritime
depuis de payer depuis bien longtemps
qu'ils deviennent de plus en plus
sophistiqués parce que la mer est aussi
un enjeu l'espace maritime est un enjeu
important
donc là c'est un petit peu la même chose
donc il ya des moyens d'observation qui
vont permettre de repérer deux
caractéristiques qui sont basés au sol
et y en a aussi
il y en a aussi qui est qui qui vont
être effectivement en orbite c'est à
dire loin de la terre notamment à trente
six mille kilomètres de distance sur les
orbites géostationnaires qui vont
permettre aussi avec des petits
satellites en particulier guetteurs qui
vont permettre d'inspecter de regarder
ce qui se passe et d'avoir des moyens
d'observation qui soit plus plus plus
performant plus que ce dont on peut
disposer actuellement donc le premier
pas de cette politique effectivement de
mise en place de deux moyens de de
réponse pour faire face effectivement
cette militarisation c'est d'avoir
d'abord des moyens de compréhension et
d'observation de ce qui se passe on a on
a bien utilisé mon militarisation mais
je vous ai posé une question sur la
rationalisation qu'on entend aussi
beaucoup quelles sont les différences
entre ces deux termes
oui alors je suis pas certain de france
les deux termes sont employés de façon
un peu
un peu similaire enfin ce qu'on dit en
fait c'est que l'espace enfin l'espace a
été et est toujours enfin il faut aussi
voir les choses telles qu'elles sont
l'espace est aussi un lieu qui reste
pour l'instant et pacifique
c'est un espace qui est c'est un lieu
qui reste effectivement un espace de
deux collaborations enfin il ya de
multiples projets de coopération entre
les grandes nations et maintenant des
plus petites nations aussi on le voit
dans la station c'est dans l'espace
situation spatiale les programmes
d'exploration et c'est bon mais l'espace
est devenu aussi un enjeu de faim un
lieu de confrontation potentiel de
menaces qui sont pas encore avérées donc
je pense que militarisation ça veut dire
ça veut dire que finalement il ya un
risque effectivement un risque de deux
confrontations
deux confrontations qui peut qui peut
aller jusqu'à la volonté de certains
états de certaines puissances de
neutraliser d'endommager tel ou tel
satellite qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
d'observation télécommunications de
position de navigation en traitement
pour l assister à une guerre dans
l'espace à la destruction d'un satellite
d'un pays par un autre pays
donc la guerre est possible au dessus de
nos têtes et quelles conséquences
après bah oui enfin oui pour employer le
mot de guerre je pense que la guerre est
quelque chose de possible
alors qu'ils auraient enfin moi je suis
pas militaire je suis pas politologue
donc j'aurai pas m'exprimer sur qui
aurait intérêt à la monnaie mais mais
mais effectivement la guerre est
possible il est possible effectivement
techniquement de neutraliser des moyens
satellitaires des constellations part
plaint d'ailleurs de moyens qui sont
connus ça peut aller aussi jusqu'à las
des attaques des attaques cyber puisque
bon finalement des satellites ce sont
des moyens qui sont très largement
informatique qui communiquent
effectivement par des liaisons ter terre
terre entre la terre et puis les
satellites donc des virus après des
attaques informatiques peuvent aussi
neutraliser des moyens ou les endommager
très fortement
donc oui la guerre est possible il ya de
multiples façons d'amener
de rendre inopérant effectivement des
satellites et les conséquences de sa
serait considérable parce que imaginer
un monde sur le dans lequel
effectivement des moyens la phrase
structure satellitaire serait totalement
ou partiellement détruites
c'est un monde qui fonctionnerait plus
sur le plan à la fois militaires mais
sur le plan économique aussi
voilà donc ça fait partie effectivement
des menaces qui qui sont qui existe est
ce qu elles se transformeront ça je n'en
sais rien mais en tous les cas elle
existe et l'espace est encore un lieu
pacifique mais n'est plus que ça il peut
devenir effectivement un espace de
confrontation dans lequel des nations ou
des groupes peuvent intervenir pour
effectivement détruire et et causé des
dommages considérables
les boîtiers rester avec nous c'est la
pose de cette grande interview on se
retrouve dans un
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande île interview
sur rtl france pour évoquer la
militarisation de l'espace avec notre
invité philippe gauthier le président de
la société et mejia philippe en était en
train d'évoquer une possible guerre au
dessus de nos têtes
entre entre les satellites entre les
différentes nations ou groupes ou
puissance la france ou est ce qu'elle se
situe par rapport à cela sa stratégie
elle est plutôt défensive ou offensive
oui alors enfin je crois qu'il faut
rappeler que la france est une très
grande nation dans le domaine spatial
qui a une tradition en fait qui datent
de longues années alors l'histoire
spatiale est assez courte
elle commence dans la fin des années 50
donc à l'échelle de notre histoire c'est
assez court mais néanmoins on a fêté
récemment le 60e anniversaire de l'
agence spatiale française le le cnes
donc il faut quand même rappeler que la
france n'est pas le plus grand pays au
monde comme chacun le sait mais tu es
une très grande nation en matière de
spatiale en possède effectivement toutes
les compétences toutes les compétences
que ce soit dans le domaine des lanceurs
évidemment en association avec nos amis
européens dans le domaine des danseurs
domaine des satellites dans le vin ce
qu'on appelle les segments sol dans le
domaine des équipements tous les
équipements qui sont embarqués dans le
domaine des des dents sur les satellites
donc la france à la fois une tradition
une expertise et une offensive ou
défensive alors la france voit la france
à une posture je crois que enfin la
doctrine militaire de la france c'est
pas de mener c'est pas d'agresser les
autres c'est d'abord effectivement de
défendre ses intérêts de sauvegarder son
autonomie stratégique c'est à dire que
la france a toujours souhaité dans le
domaine militaire
avoir ses propres moyens et avoir ses
capacités propres de se faire une
appréciation très concrètement ça veut
dire avoir ses propres satellites par
exemple d'observation la france dans
quand elle quand elle décide
effectivement intervenir seul ou en
en coalition en alliance souhaite
effectivement disposer de ses propres
informations et ne pas dépendre si vous
voulez de tel ou tel autre fournisseur
d'image par exemple donc ça la position
de la france et d'avoir effectivement
une autonomie de d'appréciation une
autonomie de renseignement une autonomie
en termes de communication
et donc je pense encore une fois je le
précise chez industrielle donc je
m'exprime pas au nom évidemment de
quelques militaires ou politiques
la position de la france est de
sauvegarder cette autonomie de
sauvegarder cette souveraineté en
matière en matière de défense donc à
regret pour répondre à votre question
donc pour répondre à votre question de
façon précise je pense que c'est pas une
position offensive c'est d'abord une
position défensive enfin voilà de
protection effectivement de ses intérêts
à la fois militaire économique
bon ceci dit protéger protéger ses
intérêts de façon défensive ça veut
aussi dire ça veut aussi dire si on est
agressé avoir des capacités à riposter
bon sinon en matière militaire ne faire
que constater effectivement des menaces
c'est pas ça fait forcément suffisant
pour protéger ses intérêts tout à
l'heure vous avez vous évoqué la
collaboration entre les entre les
nations dans l'espace vous évoquiez
notamment à la station spatiale
internationale avec thomas pesquet et
aussi des russes des américains des
chinois des japonais qui se retrouvent
ya plusieurs nations qui collaborent la
france collabore souvent avec le s1
l'agencé spatiale européenne
on sait qui est aussi la nasa ya
roskosmos chez les russies aussi l'agent
ce naze en agence chinoise
la france est ce qu'elle est
véritablement avec l' agence spatiale
européenne ou est ce qu'elle est plus
seul comment est-ce qu'elle collabore
dans tout ça obama il nous faudrait il
nous faudrait il nous faudrait je pansse
un très long et très longtemps pour pour
faire la liste effectivement toutes les
coopérations il ya un outil vous avez
cité les pays enfin les sites les pays
que vous citez sont effectivement les
les pays avec lesquels la france
collabore de façon très intensive
souvent effectivement par le biais des
différentes agences nationales
ou internationales comme l'agencé
spatiale européenne oui vous citiez
thomas pasquet on peut citer
effectivement la mission
la mission mars avec superbe
atterrissage récemment et des
instruments français qui sont qui sont à
bord à bord de cette mission
bon voilà donc il ya donc à une
collaboration qui est vraiment multiples
au niveau scientifique au niveau
industriel aussi sacré effectivement
enfin et mejia y participent
sacré également tout un système de
réseau que ce soit au niveau européen ou
au niveau des coopérations avec avec la
russie avec les chinois vous signaliez
avec avec avec les états unis
donc il ya une collaboration qui est
très très forte c'est quand même
important de le signaler
bon certes il ya du danger mais mais
mais il ya aussi il ya aussi quand même
énormément de coopération et on est
obligé de coopérer parce que bon il ya
de tels enjeux financiers on peut pas je
crois qu'il ya plus beaucoup de nations
qui sont capables de travailler de façon
totalement autonome on parle de la
coopération parler de danger également
potentiellement une guerre au dessus de
nos têtes mais récemment il ya eu des
traités qui ont été soit déchiré soit
prolongée traité est fini qui a été
rompu de manière unilatérale par les
états unis après la russie a suivi a
fini ça veut dire forces nucléaires
intermédiaire puis ensuite il ya eu en
janvier
la prolongation du traité new start pour
le désarmement entre les nations à ce
que c'est un espoir une inquiétude à
long terme comment est ce que vous vous
voyez ça sachant que vous travaillez
justement dans la militarisation de
l'espace elle en parle de d'armes
nucléaires justement je pense que la
militarisation de l'espace c'est ça
aussi essayer de regarder ce qui se
passe d'un point de vue nucléaire ouais
alors là je ne saurais pas vous dire
exactement quelle à l'intersection entre
le sujet nucléaire et puis et puis sujet
de l'espace ce qui est vrai c'est que
bon il ya il ya un certain nombre de
traités finalement fondateur dans le
domaine de l'espace qui qui en qui on
est et qui ont été menées notamment un
traité datant de 1967 et qui est qui et
qui finalement stipule le fait que
l'espace et à tout le monde et l'espace
net à personne donc il n'y a pas de
notion de souveraineté
de tel ou tel pays dont sur l'espace
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
très important sans fin contrairement
par exemple si je prends je continue
avec le parallèle dans le domaine
maritime ou là un pays à une zone
effectivement sur lequel il s'ouvre à
autour de ses côtes
donc voilà donc il ya des il ya des
traités effectivement fondateur qui sont
des traités d'ailleurs qui vont dans le
sens d'un esprit totalement pacifique et
collaboratif universel
voilà donc effectivement je pense que il
y aura forcément effectivement une un
certain nombre de traités alors je sais
pas s'ils sont bilatéraux ou
multilatéraux qui devront réguler un
certain nombre de choses dans le domaine
de l'espace mais mais dans le domaine
militaire effectivement éviter l'emploi
de telles ou telles armes dans le
domaine dans l'espace il ya aussi des
sujets qui sont des sujets de régulation
du trafic puisque encore une fois je le
disais l'espace est tellement encombrées
va devenir tellement encombrées avec des
dizaines de milliers de satellites qui
va falloir au même titre qu'on l'a fait
en son temps dans le code de la route ou
vous ou dans la régulation du trafic
aérien il va falloir écrite yvan
s'occuper d'eux de l'établir plus de
règles et de les faire respecter est
d'avoir les moyens effectivement
technique de les faire respecter
donc c'est vrai que l'espace va très
probablement
devoir faire face à une structuration en
terme de règles de traiter très
importante donc et le volet militaire
est probablement l'un de ces de ses
volets on a évoqué en tout temps les
collaborations entre états de puissance
ont annoncé dernièrement de vouloir
créer une base lunaire à l'horizon 2035
avec une construction qui devrait
commencer en 2026 selon les annonces
c'est la russie et la chine les etats
unis eux souhaitent revenir sur la lune
en 2024
c'est vous évoque quoi tout ça la lune
d'un d'un côté de la militarisation de
l'espace pour votre société mejia est ce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on regarde ce
que c'est quelque chose d'intéressant ou
est ce que c'est juste l'exploration
spatiale et la conquête spatiale
ou est-ce que ces militaires bah écoute
et oui ça c'est un problème
enfin un problème ou un sujet qui est
intéressant enfin pour ce qui nous
concerne en fait nous aimer rien pour un
petit peu vous vous situez façon
d'autant procède on s'éloigne
progressivement de la terre parce que
plus vous allez loin plus c'est quand
même compliqué en termes de technologies
vous avez des des sujets de d'énergie
des sujets de 2,2 radiations spatiales
enfin il ya tout un tas enfin c'est un
petit peu encore une fois comme comme un
bateau plus vous avez loin des côtes
plus c'est compliqué quand même donc le
spatial c'est pareil donc on a
progressivement nos premiers petits
satellites se sont se déploie dans assez
proche de la terre c'est à dire de leurs
2 500 kilomètres on va aller plus loin
on va aller à trente six mille
kilomètres mais ça nous permet de
développer les technologies qui vont
pouvoir
s'appliquer sur surba disons du voyage
interplanétaire et de sortir
effectivement de désorbiter terrestre
donc oui on va on va suivre
effectivement ce mouvement et proposer
des solutions de véhicules en fait
qu'ils seront plus forcément appelée
satellite de véhicules qui vont
participer en fait aux commissions aux
missions lunaires martienne et c'est
donc on pourra imaginer aussi d'avoir
d'ailleurs peut-être des satellites qui
tourne autour de la lune ou de telle ou
telle planète dans un avenir plus ou
moins proche
voilà donc le mouvement et la famille
doit continuer pour cette fois-ci et
faire de la militarisation de l'espace
au niveau de la lune pour voir ce qui se
passe sur la lune quand tu auras des
bases et tout ça c'est ça que vous êtes
entre wayne dire basse que ce qu'on peu
ce qu'on peut imaginer si vous voulez
c'est que pourquoi pourquoi on va aller
à terme pourquoi on va aller plus loin
on peut on peut imaginer c'est un petit
peu la conquête mois j'assimile ça un
petit peu à la conquête des amériques si
vous voulez on va on va on va
progressivement les nations vont vouloir
aller effectivement explorer le monde
interstellaire et donc il va y avoir
probablement des sujets des sujets de
territoire il va y avoir des sujets
aussi de matières premières de de
ressources en fait en termes de 2,2
voilà deux des sujets d'hégémonie donc
oui il va falloir je pense pas que les
choses vont nécessairement l'homme étant
ce qu'il est les nations étant ce
qu'elles sont il va pas y avoir
forcément que du pacifique et du
collaboratif dans cette conquête de
l'espace dans cette exploration
même si les les moyens considérables
qu'il faut déployer à la fois en termes
financiers en termes industriels et en
termes scientifiques nécessite des
coopérations qui ce qui se met en place
voilà donc une société commerçante de
secondes vous venez de parler de
l'aspect financier c'est quoi le budget
de l'espace en france et comparativement
par rapport aux autres pays on se situe
où le budget en fait alors
institutionnels
c'est à dire
le budget le budget est effectivement de
la france et de leurs 2 3 milliards
d'euros est bon
je pense que les états unis par exemple
c'est de l'ordre de 10 à 15 fois plus
quoi enfin typiquement mais la france
est quand même dans dans l'est dans les
trois quatre premières nations mondiales
en termes effectivement de de
compétences et d'investissement dans
spécial
merci beaucoup fi des boîtiers d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur le thème de
la militarisation de l'espace rappelle
que vous êtes le président de la société
et mejia qui collabore donc avec l'état
français sur cette mission merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de cette grande
interio vous pouvez la revoir en replay
en podcast sur arte france pointé vais
passer une excellente journée sur arte
france paille
[Musique]